[Music]
on this Thursday night progress on the
path to reopening what's coming back
slowly in Ontario when and what's still
cut off look at my hair I looked like a
sheepdog as rules relax in other places
including Alberta but not in all cities
so we're gonna have to reschedule you're
claiming thousands of Canadian meat
inspectors infected with kovat 19 the
anxiety levels are increasing the
pressure to protect them and the strain
on our food supply
a top US scientist turned whistleblower
Americans deserve the truth the truth
must be based on science his blunt
testimony and warning the US has no
pandemic master plan plus calling out
the lies conspiracy theories flare up
about 5 g and kovat 19
global national with Donna freezin
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
with the May long weekend just around
the corner we're all looking for signs
of a return to something close to normal
and in some parts of this country there
is a bit of good news what you'll be
allowed to do this long weekend though
depends on where you live
Alberta reported 50 new cases of kovat
19 today in most of the province
restaurant bars retail stores and hair
salons got the go-ahead to reopen today
with strict physical distancing rules in
place in Calgary though Alberta's
largest city and the city of Brooks
nothing changes
Heather York's West explains why yes
this was supposed to be reopening day at
hair booth house the Calgary salon was
booked solid but instead of doing hair
stylists here are busy rebooking their
clients after learning late Wednesday
that plans to reopen were being delayed
we know it's for the best but you know
it's it's a little frustrating just
because they gave us less than 24 hours
so calling clients and rescheduling
everyone is a little bit hard across
much of Alberta the number of new kovat
19 cases has fallen and hospitalization
rates are low in fact most of the cases
in this province are confined to two
municipalities Calgary and Brooks were
outbreaks at nearby meatpacking plants
have contributed to large clusters of
infection in these municipalities we
must recognize a higher number of cases
we continue to see compared to the rest
of the province I know this may be
frustrating for some residents and
businesses but we ask you to be patient
your safety remains our top priority
restaurants in these centers will now
have to wait until at least May 25th
before opening to guests but this
business owner feels even that day is
too soon we're not planning to open
until maybe July 1st just after July 1st
we'd like to make sure that we have
everything in place properly safe
procedures staffs ready to come back and
make sure that the guests feel
comfortable when we're
until then the eatery is focusing on
takeout bringing in just a fraction of
what an open dining room normally does
but Alberta's economy was struggling
heading into the Colvin night teen
crisis and it's been made worse by a
collapse in the price of oil unlike
anything the sector has ever seen
it has been a painful time for many and
recovery is not likely to happen anytime
soon it'll be tough it was tough in the
last little bit with the downturn in the
economy but now is gonna be even harder
I think it'll be very very hard other
Eurex West Global News Calgary Ontario
is starting phase one of its reopening
plan there were 258 new confirmed cases
there today and that is the lowest
single day increase since March public
health officers say the downward trend
means some restrictions can carefully be
lifted on Saturday private parks
campgrounds marinas and golf courses
will be allowed to reopen restrictions
are also being lifted on more retail
stores workplaces and construction sites
in all cases physical distancing and
hygiene rules must be obeyed Ontario
Premier Doug Ford says businesses should
only reopen if they are ready we cannot
let our guard down now we must watch the
trends like a hawk as we get more and
more people back to work the risk of
flare-ups is real so we need to stay
vigilant
Eric Sorenson takes a closer look at
Ontario's reopening plan and why some
businesses will have to wait the Ontario
government has given the green light to
some activities to get rolling this long
weekend marinas and boat clubs private
parks and campgrounds and golf courses
it's a short summer in this country and
this Ottawa Golf Club is scrambling to
be open Saturday with distancing and
other rules I just committed that
Clubhouse and every phone in the
clubhouse was on hole there ringing so
people are excited to get out more
businesses can open next Tuesday
retailers with Street entrances all
construction can resume as well as
surgeries and other medical services
plus household cleaning and maintenance
seasonal sports venues like tennis
courts Pet Grooming serve
and off-leash dog parks we're getting
thousands of people back to work we've
laid a solid foundation for economic
reopening and recovery there's almost a
sense of pride among Ontarians for
getting to this point
everyone in Ottawa's you know playing
playing our roles properly and I'm glad
to see that I think nice spring day and
room for some more optimism we've come a
long way since we batten down the
hatches two months ago though fatality
numbers remain a concern in March 33
people in Ontario died from coke at 19
in the first two weeks of May 716 people
have died but it's deemed safer now
because hospitals have shown the
capacity to cope and testing has
increased to better monitor the virus
now that we've been able to sort of get
make real impact with those measures you
now start looking at all of the other
concerns because the economic concerns
are real it's not at all to underplay
that I'm and to say what can we safely
do at the same time the public's anxiety
has diminished over time people sense of
risk is now growing into a little bit
for some people impatient because they
kind of are not seeing the risks in
immediate sense some businesses like
restaurants didn't make the cut a little
too intimate to open yet same for
hairdressers and barbers even the
premier miss is that look at my hair I
look like a sheepdog right now
I think dog grooming I should go there
get a little clip myself jokes aside the
aim is step by step to limit new
outbreaks and prevent having to roll
back what's being opened first Eric
Sorenson Global News Toronto next door
Quebec is still by far the hardest hit
province in Canada today it reported 793
confirmed new cases and 131 more people
have died there that brings the death
toll in Quebec to more than 3,300 many
of Quebec's cases and deaths are
concentrated in the montreal area and
that is forced officials to rethink
their reopening plans they had said
montreal elementary schools would reopen
later this month but that has now been
pushed back to September we've concluded
that the conditions are not met
to reopen elementary schools in the
montreal region's premier Legault
strongly recommends people in montreal
wear face masks in public to help limit
the spread of the virus the province
plans to work with manufacturers to get
more masks into the city with
restrictions relaxing the pressure is on
to ensure people who are working are
properly protected that includes the
people who inspect our food since
mid-april cases of kovat 19 among food
inspectors has been rising steadily as
David akin reports it's putting major
strain on Canada's already bruised food
supply system by law no meatpacking
plant in Canada can operate without one
a meat inspector they make sure that
Canada's food is safe but right now
Canada's 1,500 or so federal meat
inspectors are worried about their own
safety so our folks are you know they're
getting more and more concerned the
anxiety levels are increasing and we're
seeing more and more infection rates in
our members as well the agriculture
union represents those who work for the
Canadian Food Inspection Agency or CFIA
it says 40 of its members have been
diagnosed with Cova 19 inspectors work
in the plants themselves and so when the
plants workers get sick the inspectors
get sick every plant in Canada is that
to put in place safety protocols we've
essentially followed the CFI guidance
local and federal public health
authorities guidance to make sure we
take every measure possible to ensure
that we are providing a safe working
environment but the CFIA is under
pressure to keep sending inspectors into
plants so the plants can keep operating
you're looking at scenarios where people
are being sent in to her despite the
fact that what all the measures being
put in place to date we haven't been
able to control the spread of kovat 19
but the CFIA is having trouble finding
enough inspectors so much so it is
threatening disciplinary action against
employees resisting reassignment as
inspectors getting that balance right is
extremely important
need to ensure that essential services
like the food supply continue to float
to Canadians but we need to make sure
we're doing everything we can to keep
workers safe Ottawa and several
provincial governments have provided
millions so far to buy personal
protective equipment for workers but the
industry says more is needed as
processors are forced to do complete
plant redesigns to keep workers and
inspectors safe in a time of pandemic
David akin global news Ottawa Canadians
had record levels of household debt
before the pandemic now the Bank of
Canada warns it's likely to rise and
become acute for households whose
incomes don't fully recover from the
pandemic and some may not be able to
make mortgage payments under a worst
case scenario the bank says the mortgage
arrears rate will top out at about 0.8
percent that's twice as high as during
the 2009 financial crisis that number
could spike this fall once payment
deferral plans offered by the big banks
are set to expire the Bank of Canada
says about one out of every five
homeowners does not have enough money to
cover two months worth of expenses the
situation is even more stark in the
United States where millions are out of
work nearly three million Americans
filed for unemployment benefits last
week alone that is down slightly from
the week before but over the last two
months 36 million people in the u.s. his
file have filed for unemployment
benefits and that is close to the entire
population of Canada those record job
losses are a big part of what's driving
the push to reopen the economy in the
u.s. today the Trump administration's
response to the pandemic came under more
scrutiny a whistleblower who was ousted
from his post as a top health official
testified the US has no master plan and
is not prepared to distribute a vaccine
if one becomes available
Jackson prosecco reports Americans
deserve the truth the truth must be
based on science painting a stark
portrait of a failed US government
response dr. Rick bright laid out the
pre-pandemic warnings that were ignored
by the Trump administration our nation
was not as prepared
as we should have been at one point
recalling an email from a u.s. supplier
of medical masks area 95 rest person I
was was completely decimated and he said
we're in deep the world is and we need
to act and I've pushed that forward to
the highest levels I could
that was before nearly 85,000 Americans
have lost their lives right now believes
the u.s. faces the darkest winter in
modern history if it doesn't come up
with a national coronavirus strategy
soon the window is closing to address
this pandemic a response that includes a
plan to roll out a vaccine which bright
cautions may not happen as soon as
predicted a lot of optimism is swirling
around a 12 to 18 month time frame if
everything goes perfectly we've never
seen everything go perfectly I think
we're gonna have a vaccine by the end of
the year brights career expertise has
not been welcomed by the White House he
was forced out of his job as director of
the Federal Office in charge of vaccines
after questioning the use of unproven
kovat 19 treatments like
hydroxychloroquine pushed by the
president he looks like an angry
disgruntled employee but the voices of
dissent are growing louder there is a
real risk that you will trigger an
outbreak you may not be able to control
this week America's top infectious
disease expert dr. Anthony Fauci
questioned the wisdom of reopening
schools and the economy as Trump has
wanted to me it's not an acceptable
answer but polls show Americans are
worried about reopening too quickly and
increasingly they disapprove of the job
president Trump is doing handling the
crisis days of damaging testimony create
the impression that if there is a plan
it's coming too late
Donna Jackson Prosecco in Washington
thanks when saying I do become I can't
coming up how Kovach 19 is put a hold on
destination weddings
you
national parks are still closed for the
May long weekend but plans are underway
to partially reopen some parks and
historic sites on June 1st trails green
spaces and day use areas will be open
where it's possible to maintain physical
distancing camping though will not be
allowed Ottawa is now working with the
provinces to try to align the opening of
national and provincial parks summer
vacations this year are most likely
going to involve staying close to home
one of the hardest-hit sectors has been
the tourism industry as Mike Jolie
explains thousands of people have had to
put their trips of a lifetime on hold
leaving nothing to chance
Miranda st. Onge knew her destination
wedding timetable down to the minute
from when she her fiance Patrick booze
and their 50 guests would arrive in
Mexico to their first opportunity to
jump in the pool and then I had our bags
packed ready to go we're just about a
month away final dress fittings my
bridesmaids had their dress fittings so
yeah but kovat 19 happened so on May 3rd
they weren't on a beach they were home
in Bowmanville Ontario
their friends made them a video to cheer
them up
so smile because cuz we'll be on a beach
and let's go soon baby but internally
they were stressed out how could they
figure out a plan that works for 50
people you know everybody's going there
for a trip as well as the wedding we
didn't want anybody to lose you know all
their money like yeah what do you tell
people right they decided to postpone
until November making it happen fell on
their travel agent Lorraine Simpson
who's worked around-the-clock to
rearrange plans for over 400 clients but
travel agents only get paid when people
travel in this past week she had to
return eleven thousand dollars in
commissions it was a corporate group I
had to send back $11,600 that's a huge
amount of money for a single mom with
kids she expects to be busy again but
not until the fall highlighting how some
businesses need longer lifelines than
others we need help from the government
so we get to that point that's gonna be
the kicker
we need help to get to that point trying
to plan for the future is difficult for
agents and travelers when Ashley Craig
began organizing her July wedding in
Mexico her biggest concern was arranging
for 96 people to go with her not safety
in a pandemic over the last week or so
people our guests have been kind of
reaching out to us and just kind of
politely saying you know we're a little
bit concerned we're not really sure if
we feel comfortable traveling yet her
solution postpone it for a year not
ideal but nothing is these days micro
like Global News Toronto ahead disaster
during lockdown a powerful typhoon
batters the Philippines
a powerful typhoon is pounding the
eastern Philippines tonight with fierce
rain and violent winds of up to 150
kilometres an hour
tens of thousands of people have been
forced to flee in a country already
suffering under strict lockdown measures
because of kovat 19 the dangerous storm
is tracking towards the island of luzon
a country's most populous region
scientists believe they have found a way
to help coral reefs cope with climate
change and stop bleaching rising sea
temperatures make corals expel the tiny
colorful algae which lives inside them
this effectively starves the coral
causing them to turn white or bleach
Australian researchers have now
developed a lab-grown strain of
microalgae which can tolerate warmer
water when it's injected into coral the
l.j is able to share its heat resistant
properties researchers plan to test the
new algae a stream across a range of
coral species kovat 19 conspiracy theory
next the dangerous claims about cell
phone towers
you are watching global national
[Music]
the reason public health measures work
is because the public for the most part
believes in them trust the science and
the public health officers that trust is
crucial without it people won't comply
and we know there are many conspiracy
theories out there conspiring to erode
public trust tonight Jeff simple looks
at one of them the mistaken belief 5g
technology is tied to the Cova 19
outbreak for police in Quebec this has
fast become a familiar sight a cellular
tower set ablaze in one week police
responded to seven similar fires all
targeting cell towers they've since
arrested a couple in their 20s and are
investigating whether they might have
been motivated by a conspiracy theory
linking 5g technology to Co vid 19 there
are a lot of possible explanations that
are being thrown around as to how the 5g
peace could be you know meshed with the
Cova nineteen piece like two puzzle
pieces that don't really fit together
but you're trying to smush them together
one of the first to suggest the link was
this Belgian doctor back in January in
an interview with a local newspaper
within 24 hours the paper removed the
story but the spark of the conspiracy
had been lit the weeks that followed saw
the claim repeated over and over on
social media do you see the perfect
storm here for health issues some like
this Ontario apothecary owner posted
this YouTube video claiming 5g weakens
the immune system allowing kovat 19 to
attack
there's no reason at all to believe that
the immune system could be negatively
influenced by Eric van Rogen's
international nonprofit has been
researching the health implications of
electromagnetic radiation for 30 years
people have seen an increase in
infectious infections already a long
time ago because 3G and 4G systems
basically worked with the same type of
electromagnetic fields others like this
American doctor claimed there is no
virus at all but rather that 5g is
poisoning people's cells it doesn't make
any sense
well there is a lot we still don't know
about kovat 19 microbiologists have put
the virus under the microscope
is unequivocally a a new virus as
opposed to something related to 2 5g and
some of the hardest-hit countries such
as Italy don't even have 5g
infrastructure but those fringe beliefs
have now been pushed into the mainstream
by celebrities such as actor Woody
Harrelson and singer Keri Hilson fueling
fires on cell towers in recent weeks
across Europe the United States and now
Canada nevermind the fact that none of
the cell towers attacked in Quebec
supports 5g Jeff sample Global News
Toronto and that is global national for
this Thursday I'm Donna Friesen as some
restrictions begin to ease in parts of
this country we leave you with the
Toronto Zoo scene from a new perspective
the zoo is planning to reopen as a drive
through its testing using the walking
paths as a way to visit the animals when
it gets the green light people may catch
a glimpse of baby longlegs he was born
on Tuesdays a third-generation giraffe
for Canada's largest zoo thanks for
watching take care of yourselves bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]